marvel studios has completely captured
their audience's attention for
spider-man no way home by generating a
huge amount of two things
buzz and hype
welcome back everyone to streaming the
galaxy my name is rocket riley and today
we're going to be talking about the
upcoming marvel film spider-man no way
home and how the studio has managed to
completely capture their audience's
attention
but before we get started if you're new
to the channel please hit the subscribe
button and click the bell icon to be
notified when we upload a new video
also spoiler warning since we'll be
talking about theories and stories
surrounding the release of no way home
so if you haven't seen the newest
spider-man trailer or venom let there be
carnage then now's your time to leave
the video or stick around if you're
still interested
what just happened
now marvel studios does a great job of
capturing their audience's attention and
it starts many months in advance of any
film's actual release date they do this
by first creating hype for the movie
with a teaser trailer as well as by
creating an environment where buzz is
bound to happen
buzz is simply when the audience starts
to talk about the upcoming film such as
by instigating or spreading rumors and
news
for spider-man no way home the rumors
started shortly after the film's leading
actors shared fake names for the
upcoming film and the release of the
first teaser trailer
youtubers podcasters and online forums
started breaking down every frame of the
trailer analyzing the connections
between the previous mcu films and even
non-mcu films
rumors began with people saying that
they believe toby maguire and andrew
garfield will appear in no way home
reprising their spider-man roles after
being pulled from their own realities
although these rumors had little basis
on facts they did create a huge amount
of buzz for the film
later andrew garfield appeared on the
tonight show with jimmy fallon and he
denied any link between him and
spider-man no way home however many fans
and viewers weren't convinced leading to
even more buzz about the film
a few weeks later a video was released
depicting andrew garfield performing on
the set of no way home but just a few
days after that video's release a
youtuber shared a video on how he faked
the entire video using deep fake
technology
then several other youtubers released
videos explaining how it would be nearly
impossible to fake the supposed doctored
video
if all this sounds confusing to you
don't worry because it's confusing to
everyone else too
now there's so much up in the air it's
hard to say whether andrew garfield or
toby maguire will appear in no way home
but we do know certain other non-mcu
villains will make appearances in the
film
hello peter
in the movie's most recent trailer it
was revealed that doc ock portrayed by
alfred molina the green goblin portrayed
by willem dafoe electro portrayed by
jamie foxx and several other non-mcu
villains from the spider-verse will be
appearing in spider-man no way home
while this doesn't entirely confirm the
rumors about andrew garfield and toby
maguire appearing in the movie it does
seem likely due to the fact that
villains from those universes will be in
the film
the release of this trailer was another
form of creating hype for the movie
which led to additional buzz
the most recent hype for the film though
occurred in the after credits scene and
venom let there be carnage this scene
showed eddie brock and venom entering an
alternate reality from their own where
tom holland spider-man appeared on the
television demonstrating how some of
these villains may be entering the mcu
from their own original films
the way that spider-man no way home has
been able to continually incorporate
characters from other films and get
people talking about this incorporation
all before the movie has even been
released just goes to show how great
marvel studios is at capturing the
audience's attention for example ever
since the release of marvel's television
shows wandavision and loki on disney
plus the buzz about a multiverse has not
died down for a second
this buzz was only heightened when it
was confirmed that characters from other
universes would be appearing in no way
home
now that the audience is able to
understand how impactful no way home
could be to the mcu i think it's likely
that it will be almost as successful as
avengers end game if not even more so
simply because of the enormous amount of
hype and buzz surrounding this movie
and ultimately that's what any studio
should do for their upcoming large
budget films create hype for the project
as well as an environment where buzz is
likely to occur
months before it's set to release and
then slowly let out more information in
order to stay top of mind and to create
additional buzz
marvel studios has been at this for over
a decade and they have seemingly
perfected the art of capturing their
audience's attention
now we just have to wait and see if
spider-man no way home lives up to the
hype on december 17th
well that's gonna be everything from us
today on spiderman no way home if you
enjoyed the video please hit the like
button and don't forget to subscribe for
more great content what are your
spiderman theories was the andrew
garfield video faked we'd like to know
your thoughts so drop them in the
comment section below
from everyone here at stream in the
galaxy we hope you have a great day and
thanks for watching
[Music]